all right welcome to episode 101 there's
a couple of things that I should
probably talk about one of which is
micro next an activity which was due to
like real-life circumstances and me
getting sick which I'm kind of good
enough at the moment to be doing this
again so hooray yay I was trying to say
horiba did they turn it to a yay Midway
I was really bad in any case that's why
my voice sounds really bad at this
moment and might probably just randomly
quit on me doing this video so hopefully
that it's not going to be too bad um
just for the sake of my videos I hope
that I recover soon but until then
you're going to have to do with my
crappy voice so in my crappy voice I
will try to sort of explain at this
point as I usually do is in a real
change in content when it comes to that
what sort of thing I am doing in this
episode which will mainly be finishing
up this area once again but it's gonna
be a tiny bit different today actually
did something which I've never ever done
before I don't know if I'll ever do
again because it wasn't the best of
experiences but it was still pretty fun
to do and definitely in the stream
talking with people which didn't really
work out a lot of coughing with people
as well about phone plate playtime
playground experiences and all that but
yeah that's what happens in this episode
building a playground so I was pretty
fun also trying to finish this overall
area with these last couple of houses
some simple foliage and all that good
stuff we are back to the normal schedule
to time upses no more live streams or
anything like that's um so yeah that's
how it's going to kind of go down so
what I'm doing at the moment is just
trying to get some simple windows I mean
some simple buildings in over here which
are very similar to the buildings that I
already have did once get a tiny bit of
variation and I figured all right you
don't really have this as much I think
anymore northern part of the country but
I have seen many Dutch buildings which
actually use a light blue or white to
greenish whatever very fancy bright
color and figured i could try to get a
small light blue building in there
somewhere with the same overall style
same sort of roof and same sort of
Gables but just a tiny bit of a
different
Colin when it comes to the walls which
is kind of the most spectacular thing to
talk about when it comes to this facade
really problem with this force on over
here is that I tries to do something
spectacular with a original sort of more
medieval city sort of building on the
corner over there but that just didn't
really work out in the end so in the end
I'm very sorry to spoil it for you but
after all my adventures of trying to
find out what sort of pieces I could use
for anything it turned out that
everything in the universe was against
me making that building like that so
yeah man it just in the end turn out to
be a very simple sort of standard brick
steps stair gable building which you
currently see being built at the moment
so that's kind of how that got like that
which is what I'll what I think I'll be
still spending a couple of minutes with
this overall area and facade trying to
get that all done and yeah that's
basically how that works nothing really
to New over here although I did as you
can see kind of trying to mess with
different facades and styles try to add
a bit of a change to the quite standard
rural Dutch theme it just didn't really
work out in the end so I'm very sad I'm
still crying about that but it's alright
because in the end this was odd did kind
of workout I one thing to say about it
it is a completely empty facade it does
literally nothing it has nothing in it
it is just there to look nice and be
tiny bit of a filler and to make this
area as a whole a tiny bit more cozy
because on the other side of this path
over here I will not have a complete
overkill of buildings but rather just
one building which is going to be
hopefully if all goes well somehow a
magical Dutch windmill which you can't
not have in the area and have only
talked about weenies yeah I should
definitely talk about beanies and
actually get some water for my throat
and okay I have talked about weenies
before actually King rct3 told me this a
very long time ago in the meantime I'm
actually researched we need quite a bit
we need other thing that Disney calls
large structures in their park that are
very attractive to look at and which
people just naturally walk to because
you see something really cool in the
distance you want to go there and that's
how they kind of spread the people
throughout the Polk's but also attract
people to the park in general and very
famous weenie of course got to be the
bigger castle in the middle of pretty
much every Disney park not just is it a
beautiful building it uses force
perspective to really look like a really
big building as well which it most
definitely isn't most of the castles
that Achilles from the smallest
buildings in the park but they are
really really really really high
compared to anything else in the parkin
I am pretty sure they're usually the
highest structure overall in the park
and so major weenie right there just to
get people out of the main street
because that's where you usually see
them at the end of the main street where
you have that really beautiful view of a
console the big weenie that you want to
walk towards and have that nice of you
at the end only thing is I don't think I
want to do that in that part in this
point because blatant ripoff is very
blatant just like getting that sort of
overall layout of the park is alright
but having a castle in the middle of
your park would be very very Disney ish
I could still do it and I'm not sure
about it but I would like to get some
sort of different weenie after the main
street which I still kind of I'm
thinking about but each sort of area
usually has a rini as well like for
example the for the Tomorrowland I think
that's tomorrow and the space mountain
is usually the weenie very large in high
building with a very distinctive and
recognizable sort of architecture so
that really does a good job and that as
well and I kind of want to get something
similar for the Dutch area the sort of
we need that I have at the moments in
the Spanish area though it's not really
too clear is the big station building of
the log flume it is the largest building
in that area and it's the building that
you instantly see as you walk into it
and that's kind of how I want to do that
so the windmill is obviously going to be
the winning in this sort of area that's
at least what my entire story was going
towards and that's why the windmill is
actually going to be quite important for
this area now to move away from the
weenie talk which by my son's really all
like for for a company like this knee
that is supposedly about all about the
imagination they are pretty bad when it
comes to the imagination when it comes
to coming up with terms with their
buildings in any case like there's
nobody with nobody even go to like a
Disney park if they knew that the big
castle in the middle in the middle was
called a weenie as probably the worst
thing that I would I could come up with
as an echo in any case I kind of wanted
to talk about this little rock work
place over here because as you can see I
just completely abused beach grass over
there a lot of really small shrubbery
things going on but especially beach
cross absolutely everywhere and there's
quite a taboo on that in the community
if you don't know about that [ __ ]
course is basically that we're all set
with the really light cross I can never
use it in it look like whenever
anybody's watching the stream who
doesn't know the set as soon as I bring
it out like everybody wants to have the
Sun that is it has an amazing sort of
attraction to it like everybody needs
Beach Ross as soon as you have it in
your hands you just can't let go of it
and you need it everywhere which is why
I was a bit hesitant to place it so much
in the river but the big idea that I had
over there at least it's not very big
audience isn't sort of been done before
was that I wanted to get some sort of
read look but since that isn't really
available in wallach Oh second three I
figured but not Beach cross would be the
next best thing and actually kind of
sort of lowering beach balls around
rocks in the water very shallow actually
worked out really well to sort of create
that look and I'm so really quite happy
about that also this is going to be the
playground and about that little mulch
on the corner over there as a very
awkward story and basically I didn't
have any sort of thing that I could have
over there since the particles were
conforming and rolla coast I can three
terraforming does not have curves in it
so yeah I was forced to use pathak over
soil now you could say you could use
different path covers but actually
figured it would be pretty fun to have a
night little plants over there and
actually in hindsight I do kind of like
it it was a fun little experiment and
it's always fun to place flowers and
just happy about the overall way that I
look so that was just kind of that just
kind of existed only because I was sort
of forced to and I was kind of lazy to
do anything else but now in the end it
does look pretty cool but yeah this big
little that I just say big little it is
very big sort of salman issue college
place over here it's gonna be that said
playground which was pretty funny since
and there is a dutch set which has many
Dutch and playground things in it which
I kind of know childhood memories and
all that stuff that was pretty sweet and
I just wanted to get some of those
things in there and I've no idea with
the English names are so I'm just gonna
get some whipped caps and carousels and
I will its get the slide in but that
thing was just way too large and then
people started telling me to build that
slide and make it go into the water that
was the worst idea probably ever so that
didn't happen in the end just wanted to
go with the other things leave that
slide where it was but still overall
even though you know that's the thing
with a playground playgrounds are pretty
damn empty and I did not want to get a
sort of empty look over here so decided
that I wanted to go with the mulch sort
of thing now there are two sort of ways
that people like to make playgrounds
safer at least over here either use
mulch with woodchips underneath it well
basically with chips but it turns at the
mulch over the years or you got the
rubber tiles and I wanted to try both
and actually sort of worked in the end
so that's why I am placing mulch
underneath these things which is used
usually for particles which seems to
make no sense for somewhere where you're
walking but this is to achieve that sort
of um sort of playground look that you
usually have in the Netherlands I'm
pretty sure you have it in other
countries as well at least I've seen it
in other countries as well but yeah that
was kind of like why my playground looks
like a giant planted so yeah that's the
reason and this also really helps just
make us this place look a lot less empty
as you can see just having that around
them having those little mulch kind of
covers around the
very small playground things makes them
stand out a tiny bit more makes it
entire playground look a lot less empty
and just having that tiny bit of middle
space that I still had left just put in
a little planter and your playground is
pretty much good to go I'd say most
couple of things we just wanted as
usually little pots I have way too many
pots random flowers in the Dutch area
things like that it's just that I had so
much concrete and just so much path and
buildings that I really need his get as
many pots and Link little hanging
baskets and any sort of blunder that I
could get in in this area just to make
sure that I'm had many flowers and so
that's kind of why I was abusing those
things at some point but yeah I see that
I'm running out of time and I'm actually
happy about the head for once I managed
to do not cough in this video so that is
already an amazing feat I'm really proud
of myself I'll get another glass of
water and I'll pretty much ended on this
last little note i decided to and the i
decided to just replace those lanterns i
actually found out that those lanterns
are a lot better for the english area
the lanterns that I am previously had
over here and these are the earthling
lights so you cannot go wrong with that
in any case thank you guys for watching
and I'll see you guys later see you
space cowboys